I want to take up in Volume 12, December the 4th, 1918, the effects of the imprisonment
of Jesus in his passion.
Louisa said that she spent last night in prison together with Jesus, and she sympathized
with him and flung to his knees to sustain him, and then Jesus spoke to her.
"My daughter," he said, "in my passion I wanted to suffer imprisonment also in order
to free souls from the prison of sin."
So if you look at the description that Louisa gives of Jesus in the prison, in the hours
of the passion, then you are looking at a perfect picture of man's slavery to sin.
Jesus is the pictorial manifestation of that.
Jesus says, "What a horrible prison sin is for man.
His passions chain him like a vile slave, and my imprisonment and my chains released
him and unchained him.
For the loving souls, my imprisonment formed their prison of love, in which to remain
safe and defended from everyone and everything.
Look how safe we are."
So for loving souls, now we're talking about victim souls and people in the divine will
who are very close to the Lord.
My imprisonment formed their prison of love, in which to remain safe and defended from
everyone and from everything, and it chose them to keep them as living prisons and tabernacles.
Now notice the term prison is put alongside the term tabernacle.
So we understand this then, we become his tabernacle, where he is present in us or imprisoned
in us, and then his heart becomes our tabernacle, or our prison where we are imprisoned in
his love.
So that is the image that is being used here.
And the divine will chose them to keep these loving souls as living prisons and tabernacles
where they can warm me from the coldness of the tabernacles of stone.
Now the tabernacles of stone are the dead boxes or containers that you find in the church,
but you have other containers that are meant to be living, but they're actually dead.
And more so from the coldness of the souls who imprisoning me within themselves make
me die of cold and of hunger.
So these are the really dead tabernacles of stone.
The people whose souls are dead in sin are totally unconnected with the Lord.
So Jesus then dies of cold and hunger, and that's because they neglect him all the time.
So this is why Jesus said, "Many times I leave the prisons of the tabernacles that's
in the church, and I come into your heart, also the tabernacles of stone and other people's
hearts, to be warmed from the cold and to refresh myself with your love."
And when I see you going in search of me in the tabernacles of the churches, I say to
you, "Are you not my true prison of love for me?
Look for me inside of your heart and love me."
So there's no need for us to go anywhere, go to any special shrines.
There's no need for us to go to any special events.
Everything is in your heart.
The whole mystery is there.
The presence of God is there.
You are a living tabernacle, 1 Corinthians 3, 16.
And also Luke 17, 21, "The kingdom of God is within you."
Some people find it hard to take that on board because they still want to go back to where
they were before the time in the divine will and continuing visiting shrines and so on.
So December the 10th, 1918, Jesus will speak about the effects of the prayers of the souls
who are intimate with him.
This is a very important message.
Louisa said, "I was saying to my sweet Jesus, 'See, I don't know how to do anything nor
do I have anything to give you, but I want to give you my own little trifles.
I unite these trifles of mine to the all, that is to the supreme majesty of God, what
you are,' she said, 'and I ask for souls.'
Therefore, as I breathe, my breaths ask for souls.
The beating of my heart with its incessant cry asks for souls.
The motion of my arms asks for souls.
The blood that circulates in my body asks for souls.
The batting of my eyelids, the moving of my lips, are all souls that I ask of you.
This is something that we can offer to the Lord that every single part of our being will
cry out to him in his divine will for souls.
And Louisa said, 'I ask this united with you.
That means fused in your divine will, with your love and with your will.'
Now, I've told you many times that the summary of the 36 volumes of Louisa is divine will
and love.
So we fuse ourselves in the divine will and we fuse ourselves in the divine love.
That is in the triune God.
So that all may hear my incessant cry that in you always asks for souls.
So there we have this wonderful opportunity to offer all of me to all of him and fused
all of me in all of him so that everything inside of me is asking for souls all the time.
What a beautiful idea.
So once you were saying this, Jesus moved in her interior and told her something that
I think is vital for all of us and that is that the whole spirituality of the divine
will is a living of the hidden life of Jesus in Nazareth.
It's not a public thing, it's a private thing, it's a hidden thing, nobody will know you're
doing it.
It's hidden, it's silent, it's away from prying eyes, nobody will know.
My daughter Jesus said how sweet and pleasing to me is the prayer of the souls who are intimate
with me because we are in union with him in the divine will.
How I feel my hidden life of Nazareth being repeated without any exteriority with no circle
of people, no sound of bells.
So there's no recognition, there's no prize, there's no nothing that nobody knows and
if you told them they wouldn't believe you and so you've got the safety of the hiddenness.
All neglected alone, so much so he said that I was barely known.
I kept rising between heaven and earth and I asked for souls and not even a breath or
a heartbeat escaped me which did not ask for souls.
And as I did this my blast, look at the power of his cry, my blast resounded in heaven and
drew the love of the Father to grant me souls.
And this sound reverberating in the hearts of all cried out with sonorous voice, souls.
How many wonders did I not operate during my hidden life known only to the Father in
heaven and to my mother on earth?
Now that's the template for us.
Go into your private room, shut the door, pray to your Father in secret and in that secret
place your Father will reward you, that's Matthew 6-6.
It is the same for the hidden soul who is intimate with me.
As she prays, though no sound is heard on the earth, her prayers like bells resound
more vibrantly in heaven to the extent of calling the whole of heaven to unite itself
with her and to let mercy descend upon the earth which resounding not to the hearing
but to the hearts of creatures may dispose them to convert.
So this is the wonderful thing about praying in the divine will that you are reaching souls
from within themselves because the divine will is resident in the interior of every creature
it has made and therefore we are reaching them in the place where they can be touched
and where they can be moved interiorly to respond to the Lord.
It's a wonderful thing.
So we're part of this wonderful motion of divine mercy that reaches into the depths of
men, women and children for all time to touch them and coact them to come back to the Lord.
So December the 25th, 1918, Jesus repeats his life in the soul.
So this is a continuation of the last message.
So Jesus said to Louisa, "My daughter do not repress yourself too much, courage I am
with you."
Now I usually only give you one reference for that.
There's tons of them in the Bible, Joshua 1, 5, "I will never leave you or desert you."
Even more he said, "I'm right inside of you."
So that's Luke 17, 21, "And I am continuing my life inside of you."
This is the reason why you sometimes feel the weight of justice and you'd want it to
unload itself, it would want to unload itself upon you.
You also feel the tearing of souls who want to be lost.
Now if you go to the scourging of Jesus in the hours of the Passion, Louisa will tell
you that the flesh that was actually torn from the body of Christ and fell to the ground
represented souls that were lost eternally in hell.
And that caused him more agony than the physical pain that he suffered.
So he says here to Louisa, "Sometimes you also feel the tearing of souls who want to
be lost and you feel the yearning to love me that is in everybody as well."
But seeing that you do not have sufficient love, that is on the human level, you plunge
yourself into my love and you take as much love as you want, as all should give to me.
So fusing into the humanity, divinity and will of Jesus, we can take from him everything
we need to give to others.
And there's more than an ample sufficiency.
That's a very inappropriate way to say it really, I mean there's an infinite supply.
So you will be able to take as much love for as much as all should give me.
And releasing your silvery voice, so obviously the Lord likes it, "You love me for all souls
past, present and future of PPF."
And all the other things that you do, do you think it's you that's doing it?
No, he said, and not at all, it is I.
Now, very seldom does Jesus use that expression, it is I, because the Greek version of that
is ego, Amy.
And it's exactly what God said to Moses at the burning bush when Moses said, "Who are
you?"
And it's exactly what Jesus said to the apostles on that night of the storm on the Sea of
Galilee when he walked on the water to meet them.
When they cried out, "Who are you worried that it might be a ghost?"
He said, "Ego, Amy, I am."
And so Jesus tells Louisa that this wonderful work that the divine will does in us and through
us is God working in us, what we do is we surrender and we open up and cooperate.
Do you think it's you, not at all?
It is I, ego, Amy.
It is I who repeat my life in you, which I think is the most wonderful reality if you
can even think about it for a moment that he would repeat his life in us.
I feel the yearning to be loved by you, not with the love of a creature, but with my own
divine love.
And therefore I transform you, I want you in my will, because in you I want to find the
one who stands in for me and for all souls.
Now that is the mediator who stands in the breach, defending souls to God and turning
to God looking for mercy for souls, Sam 106, verse 23.
And Jesus said, "I make you an organ which lends itself to all souls, lends itself to
all the sounds that I want to make."
So this is love without borders.
And looking for mercy without borders, we don't ask because a soul is good.
We don't ask because they have the right religion or no religion.
We ask because they belong to God, they are his, they're his images.
And so Louisa said, my love, there are certain times when life is so bitter, especially because
of the conditions you put me in.
And Jesus knew what she wanted to say, which of course is Sam 139.
He knows my thoughts before, I think them, my words before I say them.
And he knew what was in her mind, so he said, "What have you to fear?
I will take care of everything."
Now Louisa is thinking of the priests who are guiding her.
And she's a little bit worried because there's been a change and she's not completely certain
about the one that has to deal with now.
He said, "I will take care of everything.
And when one directs you, that's one priest, I will give my grace to him.
When another one comes along, I will give my grace to that other one.
And besides, it's not you whom they will assist but me.
That's Matthew 2540.
The least you do, what you do to the least of my brethren, you do to me.
It's not you whom they will assist but me.
And according to how they will appreciate my work, my sayings and my teachings so, I will
be generous to them.
So if the priest doesn't really bother himself with all of this thing, it's merely a duty
to come in and look after Louisa, then he's not going to get a lot.
If somebody else actually takes on board what Jesus is saying, he will get a lot.
And then, of course, we had Hannibal de Francea who became a saint.
So Louisa said, "My Jesus, the confessor, appreciated very much what you would say to
me so much so that he cared very much about it.
And he worked very hard to make me right.
He said, "What are you going to give him?"
I think she's talking about the one who has just died or passed on to some other task.
He said, "I will give him heaven."
If you go to Matthew 20 verses 1 to 10, you get the laborers in the vineyard and they
all get the same payment, which, of course, is heaven.
"I will give him heaven as recompense and I will count him as the office of Saint Joseph
and of my mother who, having assisted my life on earth, had to go through hardships
in order to nourish me and to assist me."
Now, since my life is in you, I hold the priest's assistance and sacrifices as if my
mother and Saint Joseph were doing them again for me.
The priest must have been very impressed by that, that Jesus would treat him as if he
were Saint Joseph and blessed mother looking after himself.
So Louisa thanked him for that.
So let's come to December the 27th, 1918, where we talk about the Word of Jesus is the
Sun or a source of enlightenment.
In these past days, Louisa said, "I had marked nothing on paper of what Jesus had told me.
I felt such listlessness and Jesus' uncommon told me, 'My daughter, why don't you write?'
In other words, she's expected to write whether she feels good or she feels bad.
The Lord expects us to do our duty, not according to our feelings, but according to the need."
He said, "Why don't you write?
My Word is light that's one John, one five.
God is light and God's Word is light."
The other way we express that is to say that God's Word gives us enlightenment, enables
us to understand the things of God.
And just as the Sun shines in all the eyes in such a way that all have sufficient light
for all their needs, so is each one of my words more than a Sun which can be light, sufficient
to illuminate any mind and warm each heart.
So each word of mine is a Sun that comes out of me, which serves you first.
That's Louisa, but when you write it, it serves others.
And then he said, "When you don't write, you come to suffocate this Sun within me and
to prevent the outpouring of my love and all the good that this Sun wants to do."
So what I want to do is give you Isaiah 55 verses 8 to 10, which I've given you a number
of times already, which is that God's way of thinking and our way of thinking is very
different.
Louisa, in all her listlessness, obviously didn't think that refusing to write anything
on paper was denying God the right to express himself.
That didn't seem to dawn on her.
I also want to give you Hebrews 4, 12, a wonderful passage about the word of God.
That it is like a double-edged sword and it gets into the place where the soul is divided
from the spirit and joints from the marrow, and that no created thing can hide from him
before whom we must give an account of ourselves.
So the word of God is the thing that must judge us or expose us to total self-knowledge first
and expose us to the knowledge of God, which is a judgment in the sense that it allows
us to make the correct decisions that we need to make.
And that word is light, grace, and the source of real repentance for us.
So Louisa said, "Ah, my Jesus, who's going to calculate on paper the words that I you
tell me?"
In other words, she just doesn't get it.
That leaving something out is as essential as Jesus says it is.
And he said, "This is not up to you to say, 'This is my business.'
Whoops, there's a little smack on the hand.
And even if the words were not calculated, which will not be, the many suns of my
words will rise majestically, placing themselves for the good of every soul past, present,
and future."
That's the good of all.
On the other hand, by not writing, you prevent the sun from rising and you would cause great
harm.
If someone could prevent the sun in the sky from rising on the Asia heavens, how much
harm would it not cause to the earth?
That one, that's the sun in the heavens, would cause the harm to nature.
But you, he said, are causing a lot of harm to souls.
And besides, it is the glory of the sun to shine majestically.
I want to give you Matthew 5, 14 to 17.
Let your light shine so that others may see it and give glory to the Father in heaven.
If the light doesn't shine, how can anybody else be enlightened by it?
So he said, the glory of the sun is to shine majestically.
In other words, everybody must see it, to understand and appreciate the wonderful gift
that the sun is giving to them.
And to take the earth and everyone as though in its hands with its light.
The harm is for those who don't take any advantage of it.
So it will be with the sun of my words.
If you go to Luke chapter 1 verse 78, the first prophecy in the New Testament is given
by John the Baptist's father, Zachariah, and he referred to Jesus as the rising sun coming
to visit us.
And so Jesus is trying to say to Louisa that every word he says is part of this rising
sun coming to visit us, letting the rays of this light actually reach us.
So it is extremely important that she doesn't prevent it.
It will be my glory to make rise as many differing enchanting and beautiful suns for
as many words as I speak.
The harm will be only then for those who refuse to participate.
Now we come to January the 2nd, 1919, and this year which is 2020, this text is very
important for me.
I can't explain just how incredibly important this is for me.
In this message we're told the heading says, "Just as in Jesus, everything must be silent
in souls."
This morning my beloved Jesus made himself seen under a storm of blows, and with his
most sweet gaze he looked at me asking me for help and refuge.
I flung myself towards Jesus to rescue him from those blows, and I enclosed him in my
heart.
Okay, so now Jesus is enclosed in her heart and he reveals what happened when he was
being scourged.
My daughter he said, "My humanity under the blows of the scourges was silent, and not
only was my mouth silent, but everything was silent in me.
A steam was silent, glory was silent, power was silent, honor was silent, everything was
silent."
So picture Jesus now receiving this absolutely atrocious scourging from men in their full
strength coming in different teams with different instruments to absolutely lacerate his flesh.
He said everything was silent.
But in a mute language he said, "For that bit I've just read I want to give you Isaiah
53 7, where they reduced him to a condition in which he looked no longer human."
But there was a mute language there, and he said, "It was eloquent, and it spoke of
my patience, my humiliation, my wounds, my blood, the annihilation of my being almost
to the dust.
For that I want to give you Philippians 2 verses 6 to 11.
His state was divine.
He did not cling to his equality with God, but he became his all men are, and becoming
like us he was humbler yet even to death, death on a cross."
That's the abyss.
And then Jesus added, "And my ardent love for the salvation of souls placed an echo
on all my pains.
Every single thing he was prepared to use it as payment, as divine currency to win souls."
Here my daughter, he said, "Is the true portrait of loving souls?
Everything must be silent in them, and around them.
A steam, glory, pleasures, honors, greatness, will, creatures themselves.
Everything must be silent, only the divine will is operative.
And if she had these, that is, glory, pleasures, honors, greatness, will or creatures, she must
be as though death, and as if she did not see anything.
On the other hand, my patience, my glory, my esteem, my pains must take over within her.
And everything she does thinks, loves, will be nothing other than love, which will have
one single echo with mine, and will ask me for souls."
So I want to give you a few scriptures there before I forget.
Isaiah 53 verses 4 to 5, 2 Corinthians 10, 5, 1 Timothy 2, 5, God wants everyone to be
saved and come to the knowledge of the truth, and Revelation 3, 20, "Behold, I knock at
the door of your heart, and if you let me in, I will come in."
My love for souls is great, as I want all to be saved, that's your one Timothy 2, 5.
"Therefore, I go in search of souls who love me, and who, taken by the same follies of my
love, would suffer and ask me for souls, but alas, how scarce is the number of those who
listened to me."
Now, I said this text was very precious to me, because when I was reading and studying
this, oh, not today, but some months ago, I said to the Lord, "I need to understand
that silence that was inside of your whole being."
And then in January of this year, I suffered a medical accident in which I wasn't given
enough an aesthetic for the eye operation I had.
So I knew I was going to feel it, and I had said to the Lord some months earlier that
the worst nightmare for me would be something going wrong with my eyes.
So he who is infinite love, he who is love itself, decided that this was a nightmare
that I would have to visit and conquer.
He doesn't want any fear to be in us, fear of anything.
And so when I realized I was going to feel the operation, instead of reacting with terror,
I asked him to let me know what this silence was.
And he gave me the grace to lie completely still on the operating table in a situation
that I thought was completely impossible for me.
And that is to endure the operation, feeling it, and the stillness was absolutely extraordinary.
As he says here, "Everything was silent.
There wasn't even a twitch in my body."
So the doctor of course thought that my eye was actually numb, because he would have expected
a violent reaction.
And that silence remained with me for 24 hours, and then I had to deal with the trauma of
the eye, and I've been dealing with it ever since.
But I wanted to know what this silence was, and of course it didn't dawn on me when I
was asking the Lord that I would of course have to go through pain to understand this
silence.
Everything was still.
My physical body, my emotions, my mind was still, my soul was still.
It was like as if time was suspended.
But it was an incredible stillness, it was a very privileged stillness, and I was able
to say to him all during that operation, which was only 20 minutes, "I surrender.
I surrender to your will.
I surrender completely to your will."
And so I give you that simply to say that if we say to the Lord that we want a particular
experience, we have to let him give it to us in the way that he decides is right.
And of course it's all divine currency, and you can save souls in the most extraordinary
way.
So January the 4th, 1919, the effects of the pains suffered in the will of God.
This is incredibly important because anything suffered in the will of God will of course
will be divine.
So continuing in my usual state, Louisa said, "I was all afflicted because of the privation
of my sweet Jesus.
I tried, however, to remain fused or united with him during the hours of the Passion.
It was precisely that of Jesus on the cross when at the summit I heard him in my interior
joining his hands and say it with an articulate voice."
Now here's Jesus praying within Louisa to ask the Lord to accept the sacrifice that
Louisa is actually experiencing.
My father he said, "Accept the sacrifice of this daughter of mine, the pain of my privation
that she feels."
Now this is the template for Louisa from now on.
Do you not see how she suffers?
The pain makes her as though lifeless without me so much so that though hidden I am forced
to suffer it together with her in order to give her strength otherwise she would succumb.
Oh please, my father accepted, united to the pain which I suffered on the cross which
of course was the privation of the father as well.
When I was abandoned even by you and concede that the privation of me that she feels, let
that be light, let it be knowledge, let it be divine life for other souls as Jesus' experience
on the cross was and everything that I myself infiltrated with my abandonment.
Now for that I want to give you two scriptures.
One is Hebrews 725, Jesus ever lives to make intercession for us.
It's permanent forever and I want to give you Philippians 4, 13.
I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength.
So what Jesus is doing here is he is getting Louisa to listen to the prayer that she should
be saying to the father about the privation instead of continuously complaining that she
finds it impossible.
So if you go to Romans 8 and I think it's 28, for those who love God all things turn out
to the good.
And also I think it's just before that that Saint Paul says that when we don't know how
to pray, I think that goes from verse 26 that the Holy Spirit prays within us according
to the mind of God.
So in those times when we feel dry and we feel that we just can't do it, just quite
simply surrender and ask the Holy Spirit to pray within you according to the mind of
God.
So Jesus hid again and Louisa said she felt as though petrified by the pain and though
crying she said, "My life, Jesus, ah yes, give me souls and may the strongest bond
that forces you to give them to me be the tormenting pain of your privation."
Okay, so now she's really using this as divine currency.
It's really wonderful at long last, okay.
And there are times when we don't want something to be divine currency, we just wanted to go
away.
But Louisa didn't want this privation to keep continuing and yet the Lord said, "No,
this is something extremely valuable."
And then Jesus came for just a little and he said, "Dough her and refuge of mine."
That's where Jesus goes to take refuge in her heart from all the sins of humanity.
What sweet harmony did your pain form today in my will?
My will is in heaven.
And since your pain was in my will, it harmonized in heaven.
And with its cry, it asked the most holy trinity for souls.
And as my will was flowing in all the angels and saints, your will asked them for souls.
So much so that all remained struck by your harmony and together with your pain, they
all cried out before the divine majesty's souls.
So now that she is praying according to the way that Jesus wanted her to pray, all of
heaven joined her and added the power of their intercessions to hers.
He said, "My will flowed in all creatures and your pain touched their hearts.
And it cried out to everyone, 'Be saved, be saved.'"
This will of mine centralized itself in you and like a refulgent sun, it placed itself
as a guard of all souls to convert them.
So here Louisa is beginning to somehow grasp that once she would make this offering in
the divine will, that this is the power of the prayer.
It is very important for us to remind ourselves of the power of prayer in the divine will.
See the great good Jesus said, yet it takes care to know the value, the incalculable price
of the divine will.
That's why it is so important to keep reading and keep studying these writings because we
have to be confronted all the time with what Jesus is saying to us.
January the 8th, 1919, the divine will has the power to render infinite everything that
enters into it.
So Louisa said, "Continue in my usual state I was all afflicted, but he came all of
a sudden, and he was tired and afflicted, although seeking a refuge inside of my heart
to escape the grave offenses that the human beings were giving to him," and he told her.
Now Jesus is now speaking about what is going on in the world in 1919, World War I is over.
It looks as if the world has gone back into peace, but that's anything but the truth because
the very frightening transformation of Russia and all its satellite states into the USSR,
this godless state in which the people were completely spiritually enslaved, and gradually
they had to stand up one by one to defend God and to defend their faith at the price of
their lives.
And so he has told us in some of the messages before now that the so-called victory would
only be apparent.
It wouldn't be a real one at all, at terrifying things were going on.
So Jesus said to her, "My daughter, hide me, I don't don't you see how they persecute
me?
They are the political leaders around the world, maybe also religious ones."
Alas, he said, "They put me out, they want to put me out and to give me the last place."
You see, God was literally not allowed to be mentioned, nobody was allowed to worship
him, their people had to worship the state.
It's actually very frightening.
So God was completely thrown out of the country entirely.
He said, "They want to put me out and to give me the last place.
Let me pour myself out," he said.
It has been many days since I told you anything about the destiny of the world.
So here he's dealing with Louisa as a prophet, so Amos 3, verses 7 to 8.
So he said, "It's been many days since I told you about the destiny of the world or
about the chastisements they snatch from me with their wickedness."
You see, the chastisements are actually made on earth and drawn out of God.
And the pain is all concentrated in my heart.
Why?
It's because God is love.
And all of these people with all their wickedness have all been created in love.
They're all created for a destiny in love eternally.
And here they're bringing hell upon the earth.
I want to say it to you to let you take part in it.
And so we will share together the destiny of the peoples.
I want to give you Galatians 6, 2 for that.
And the sharing together, sharing the burden is Matthew 18, 19.
Jesus said, "If two of you agree concerning any matter, I will ratify it in heaven."
Well, at the time, there was only Louisa and Jesus.
So let us share together the destiny of the peoples in order to pray, suffer and cry together
for their good.
Then he said, "Ah, my daughter, there will be contentions among them that is among all
the leaders.
They're not settled at all.
The fact that they've made an armistice only stopped physical fighting," that's all.
Death will claim many lives and also priests.
Now that went on for years and years and years in the Soviet Gulags.
Millions of people died.
Only God knows the number.
But all we know is that more people died as Christian martyrs in the 20th century than
in the 19th centuries added together before it.
"Oh, how many masks," he said, "dressed as priests.
I want to remove them before the persecution against my church and revolutions arrived.
Who knows?
They might convert at the moment of death."
Now, who are these masks pretending to be priests?
Well, you have to know that the infiltration of the church by the communists and then the
Freemasons have already started.
And they put men who were atheists into the seminaries, paid them to stay there and get
themselves ordained so that they could destroy the church from within.
So the mask means this is complete pretense, this is totally hypocrisy, and it's going
to be terrible destruction for the church.
Since these men were atheists, they had no grace, they had no faith, nothing.
How were they going to survive in an atmosphere of celibacy?
Well, they brought homosexuality into the seminaries, and this terrifying disease has
not yet been eradicated.
And so what was very pure before has become impure, and nothing impure or unholy can enter
the presence of God.
I want to remove them as Revelation 11, 18.
I will destroy the destroyers of the earth.
Then he says, "Who knows?
They might convert at the moment of death."
Otherwise, he said, "If I leave them there in their place in the church, during the persecution,
these masks will remove their masks.
They will unite with the sectarians."
Now, what Louisa called sectarians are Marxist, Freemasons, Illuminati, and all that are people
involved in atheistic materialism and so on.
They will unite with these people, and they will become the fiercest enemies of my church,
and their salvation will be much more difficult.
Now, you have to know that the person who started the group called the Illuminati was
a former Catholic priest.
He was a Jewish man who became a Christian, and then became a Catholic, and then became
a priest, and then rejected the priesthood, and then rejected his Catholicism, and then
rejected Christ, and set up a group that would permanently work for the destruction
of the church.
They will be my fiercest enemies, he said.
So Louisa was all afflicted, and she said, "Oh my Jesus, what pain to hear you speak
about these blessed chastisements?"
She says, "And the people, how will they manage without priests?
They are already few enough.
You want to take away more, because Louisa has no idea of what Jesus is actually talking
about.
She has no idea.
She thinks it's just ordinary priests who are not manifesting great holiness.
He couldn't have told her what I've told you.
She couldn't have hoped with it at all.
And the priests who were listening to her would not have been able to cope with it either,
because it was going to take quite some time for the church to grasp what had happened
to it."
She said, "How will they manage without priests?
They are already few enough.
You want to take away more of them, and who will administer the sacraments?
Who will teach your laws?"
And Jesus said, "My daughter, don't afflict yourself with that.
The scarce number doesn't mean anything."
He said, "I can give to one the grace and the strength that I give to ten."
Now, for that I want to give you Matthew 25, verses 28 and 29.
That is the story of the talents, where the one talent was given to the man with the ten
talents.
The Lord can distribute his gifts any ways he wants.
He said, "I'll give to ten the grace and the strength that I give to ten."
He said, "I'll give to twenty."
And one will be worth ten or twenty.
I'll make up for everything.
In other words, it's not numbers that he is concerned about.
It's quality.
That's the important thing.
"And besides, many priests who are not good are the poison of the people.
Instead of doing good, they do evil.
And I do nothing other than remove the first elements that poison the people."
In other words, the first elements are these so-called priests who will do nothing but
destroy the people because they're not even believers.
And then other priests who are affected by them will be giving this poison to people
as well.
Jesus disappeared and I remained with a nail inside of my heart for what he had told me
and almost restless, thinking of the pains of my sweet Jesus and the destiny of these
poor people.
Then Jesus came back and surrounding my neck with his arm, which is Song of Songs Two-Four.
He gave a very important message.
My beloved, he said, "Take courage, enter into me, that means fuse with me.
Come to swim in the immense sea of my volition, of my love.
Hide yourself in the uncreated will and love of your creator."
Isn't that wonderful?
The uncreated will and love is the most holy trinity.
My volition has the power to render infinite everything that enters into my will and to
raise and transform the acts of creatures as eternal acts, in fact.
What enters into my will acquires the eternal, the infinite, the immense, losing the beginning,
the finite and the littleness.
In other words, losing all that human, he constitutes it as a divine act, which is incredible.
That which my will is so it renders their acts.
Therefore, say, cry out loudly in my will, I love you.
We should say it very frequently, I love you with your will on behalf of all.
I love you with your will on behalf of all.
I will hear the note of my eternal love.
I will feel the created love hidden inside the uncreated love, and I will feel myself
loved by the soul with an eternal, infinite, immense love, and therefore a love worthy
of me, which stands in for me and which can compensate me for the love of all.
Of course, it can compensate for the love of all because it's divine, it's infinite.
Louisa said she remained surprised and enchanted, and she said, "What are you saying?"
And Jesus said to her, "My dear, do not be surprised, I love them, my dear.
Do not be surprised, everything is eternal in me.
Nothing has a beginning, nor will it have an end.
Do yourself and all souls were eternally in my mind."
This requires real, quiet meditation.
The love with which I formed the creation, which was released from me and which endowed
each heart was eternal.
What is the wonder then if the soul leaving her own will, now notice the importance of
leaving your own will, not my will, but thine be done, not my will, but thine be done?
That has to be our continuous motto.
What is the wonder then if the soul leaving her own will enters into mine?
That is fusing.
And uniting herself to the love which longed for her and loved her from all eternity,
that is Jeremiah 31-3, "I have loved you with a never lasting love, and I am constant
in my affection for you."
So she leaves her own will, she enters into mine, and uniting herself to the love which
longed for her and loved her from all eternity, and binding herself with that eternal love
from which she came.
She does her acts.
She loves me, she acquires eternal, infinite, immense value and power.
That is hard for the human mind to really take on board, so we need the Lord's enlightenment
for it.
Oh, how little is my will known, Jesus laments, therefore it is neither loved nor appreciated.
And this is why the soul contents herself with remaining down below, that means at the
earthly level and the human level where everything is utterly and completely limited and imperfect.
So she stays down below because she doesn't appreciate what's up by.
And she operates as if she did not have an eternal origin, but only a temporary one.
Jesus said, "I don't know whether I'm speaking nonsense or not, but my beloved Jesus cast
such light into my mind about His Most Holy Will, that not only am I unable to contain
it, but I lack the right words to express myself as one Corinthians 2-9.
That's beyond the mind of man.
Then while my mind was wandering within this light of the divine will, blessed Jesus gave
me a simile."
In other words, he gave her an example so that she could begin to grasp it.
So he said, "In order to make you understand better what I have told you, imagine a sun.
This sun emits many little lights, which it diffuses over the whole of creation, giving
them full freedom to live either spread out in creation or inside the sun."
Now notice the two options.
You can live spread out throughout the creation, or you can live inside the sun.
That's inside in the divine will.
So you can live inside the sun itself from which they came out.
Is it not right that the little lights which live inside the sun, that their acts, their
love, acquire the heat, the love, the power, and the immensity of the sun itself?
Because after all they're inside of it.
If I'm inside of another one won't I get its heat and it's light and won't I be cooked?
After all they were inside the sun.
They are part of the sun.
They live at the expense of the sun, and they live the same life as the sun.
They add or subtract nothing from the sun, because what is immense is not subject either
to growing or decreasing.
Only it receives the glory that is only the sun receives the glory, the honor, that the
little lights return to it, and they live common life with it.
And this is all the fulfillment and the satisfaction of the sun.
He said I am the sun.
So some people are living at a distance from him, some are living within the divine will.
And so if they're living inside of Jesus and they're part of him, they live at his expense.
They live the same life as Jesus, and therefore naturally their acts, their love, acquire,
the extraordinary heat, love, power, and immensity of divine acts.
I am the sun Jesus said.
The little lights that come out of the sun are the creation.
The lights which live inside the sun are the souls who live in my divine will.
Have you understood, and Louisa said I think so, okay.
So I want to give you Matthew 5, 14 to 17.
You are the light, okay.
So Louisa said, but who can say what I understood?
I would have wanted to remain silent, but the Fiat of Jesus did not want it, and I kissed
his Fiat, and I wrote his will.
That's the first time she has written the words I wrote in his will.
May all be blessed for him.
So I want to leave that there from all.